musicology University of China I'm
delighted to be here and sharing this
panel with two scholars the title of one
of whom is the name of the panel is from
state policy on the female voice to
women musicians narratives so dr. 90cm
deuced will be our first presenter her
paper is titled the Islamic Republic and
a solo female singing as all of you know
dr. C Auguste is a postdoctoral
associate and lecturer at the Iranian
Studies program at Yale University
she's also of author of the recently
published 2017 January 2017 publication
on the soundtrack of the revolution a
groundbreaking book on music after 1979
within Iran Stanford University Press
she does not have a table selling copies
of outside but she should and this talk
will be followed by Paola Messina who is
an associate producer at the Arab
Studies Institute her paper will be
entitled reclaiming stage and image
Iranian women
decisions in their own voices thank you
to a house thank you for sharing
hello again everyone you all have had so
enough with me if I can go back today
and certainly a begginer tomorrow so
here I go again
I'm grateful too fast limit for having
introduction and I may I may do so again
myself so the Battle of the female voice
remains one of the enduring red lines of
his long term public and in fact I chose
to open my talk with the cover of my
book again not only for promotional
purposes but also because it is quite
appropriate for my talk today the images
of the electro rock musician mark
Australian it's part of a series of
photography series by Ashok about Korean
culture listen she captures professional
female singers and the passionate act of
singing and we see these men and women
and we see the passion on their faces
the series is called listen but of
course we cannot hear them the
implication being of course that their
solo voices are banned in the Islamic
Republic so what has been the position
of the state on the solo female voice
those who know me ground of course know
that before the 1979 revolution some of
Iran's greatest singers of all times
have been women and some of them still
continued to command huge audiences
across the world
for example guru short of hanging stuff
in fact Iran had a very early
emancipatory figure a figure of a female
singer in the in the person of a lot
about who buy CDs on it who did a
groundbreaking act very early on in 1924
at the techmount Grand Hotel and many
month you will know this anecdote of
singing to mix gender audience unveiled
and in fact singing of their sort of
auntie bathing song based on the item
you saw this is something that I drew
from a piece that Professor of
attraction he was present here wrote
without the importance of female singers
in Iran and the cabaret performer
mahashiv emissions
all times today so we have Musha in the
large photograph come out of there a
montage of course was so popular that
when she died prematurely and car
accident in 1961 the fear of processions
for her passing were the largest public
gathering that Tehran had ever witnessed
Gabriel II and the salon for to me have
written about some of these figures and
popular performers including Jewish as
has files on the Hamas CN as I mentioned
who shangzhou be about their performance
and premies Musa fighted has written
about female singing in
post-revolutionary Iran with a focus on
Pat ISA but the newly instituted Islamic
Republic official Dom viewed music as
suspect and I think after having sort of
had a centuries-long review of the
issues surrounding music and morality
today turns out these lawmakers [ __ ]
is not the first and certainly not the
only ruling authority to have a problem
with music and women within that
particular role after all revolutionary
Ayatollah Khomeini as first his first
attack on music was that it should be
eliminated completely that I corrupted
the youth and that it was like opium so
among those musicians who stayed in Iran
the ones worst affected were of course
women and in particular women vocalists
Majid direction a member of the
important rubbish group early on in the
early years of the revolution a composer
and a tarp layer relate to me the
anecdote of how forces of the
revolutionary forces basically stormed
their building
soon after the Revolution and asked for
two of the childish tapes first of all
asked for hanging on Avon and see Medina
were the two female vocalists of chop
wish to leave the group and for also
those tapes to be changed and the
segments that they had sung to be taken
out of those tapes and unlike many
others however many women of course were
stopped in their tracks but many did
continue in their in their perseverance
and following basically their their
professions see Mabini was one of them
she was a member of the bush and
a highly accomplished musician of
Persian classical music she managed to
she's today perhaps the foremost expert
on folkloric music and gives concerts to
sold-out audiences across the world
other prominent singers like Simeon Khan
M Harries angin Anthony Maliki who
stayed in Iran eventually started giving
concerts to all female audiences nearly
two decades into the revolution the
state came up with what the given
frameworks for that other singers still
such as for example mass about that and
sort of members of the younger
generation they simply refused to sing
in all-female to all-female audiences
and the most prominent among those is of
course Pat Issa who to this day has
refused to sing inside Iran and but
commands huge audiences abroad yet
others have managed to sort of you know
play with the rules of the system and
publish their voices in multi vocal
records or in other ways that is sort of
permitted so either by the male singer
of lowering their voices while so that
the female voice can become more
prominent but at the end of the day
women musicians cannot publish records
that features their souls solo so how do
the official bodies of the Islamic
Republic justify this ban against the I
have some photographs of some of the
musicians who have persevered and and
published many great works in
post-revolutionary Iran but how do
official bodies of these lawmakers
Republic justify the span against the
female voice or I should probably ask is
there actually a ban against the female
voice and that's where things actually
get interesting the core of this issue
has to do with the term but not in
Islamic law which refers to a kind of
singing that comes from the throat and
causes Tara Tara Ben turn is defined as
a state where and one is overly
enraptured and excited due to immense
ecstasy or overly stressed and perturbed
due to immense sadness Nanai is usually
the fair at gatherings of amusement and
vanity
music on the other hand how meny defines
as the sound that comes from musical
instruments not meant for such
gatherings of joy and leisure however
how many also explains that certain
kinds of pen are singing from the throat
are Hollow and excluded from the above
definition namely the kinds of singing
that remind the human being of
righteousness such as songs of
lamentation and Quranic recitation and
the songs of camel herders and songs in
weddings altogether when asked who
decides what is openam Khomeini says
Orpheus it's based on convention this is
a print out of a a copy of his last
fatwas on music and it's very small
print and a little hard to see but if
you look at the first item there the
question is a blonde fair moody buy at
family piety Musafir motor Haram fan
Moody's kaymu severe motor Haram
asvatthama cook ashkali nada and Tosh PC
in our boutique he's previously you said
that motoric music is haram and mass
cookie voices sort of that are up to
question don't have a prop and the ones
that are mash book that are up for
questions don't have a problem so who
decides this and he says it's uh it's up
to convention so when you look at that
it's bass you can see how that wouldn't
really clarify anything in a highly
contested cultural and political space
like that of the Islamic Republic what
is Convention and who really decides
convention it's a highly convention is a
highly problematic term for it for the
determination of that female singing was
so widely considered unacceptable in
traditional settings that all-female
singing was at first automatically
relegated to the category of Fenna as
patty saw told Musa fatty she was just
told soon after the Revolution that she
could no longer sing or teach singing
because the female voice was
polly haram toward the late 80s when in
a series of very public jurisprudential
argumentations and reasonings between
various leading ayatollahs and Miraj
attack lead sources of emulation the
islamic republic instituted the policy
of mass lahat expediency so giving
preferences to policies that were in the
interest of the nizam of the state even
if they contravened the Shariah that is
basically what masla had or the policy
of expediency means Khomeini so toward
the late 80s based on the principle of
mass lahat established at the sale of
musical instruments and the promulgation
of certain kinds of music was permitted
after all this was best recorded in a
conversation between Romania and
rafsanjani then president iPod
rafsanjani which was later reported by
home a nice son Ahmed in a public speech
rafsanjani asked the leader previously
you declared that music was forbidden
why do you no longer object to it the
Imams answer was let us assume that the
music in question was broadcast by the
radio of Saudi Arabia the source of all
evil info manias view then I would
forbid it because wherever target
meaning site of Satan or idol worship is
in power opposition to what he
undertakes is allowed and such
opposition conforms to mass lahat but
excuse me but here where the Islamic
state is in power a different form of
regulation is valid so even in the
question to Imam Khomeini back then in
February 1988 when he did mention the
notion of mass lahat basically he's in
his last fad was on music nobody even
asks him whether the solo female voice
is permitted that's how out of question
it was so in the questions put to
Khomeini in in the last etc in the last
test if does that he received you see
number six again it's a quite sort of
fine print the question is I am eat a
banana Jake as a mousse idiom oh Jesus
today
and between host of enemy is it is it
permitted to use the solo voice of a man
and he says basically the the fatwa is
the same as I have previously given so
the the fatwa is if it doesn't have any
if there's no facade in and if there's
no corruption in it it doesn't lead to
laughs if doesn't lead to the kind of
idol worship or you know removing
oneself from God then it's permitted and
then the question number seven the
second one up there is Channel today I J
cattle Moo city knows mr. day's a nun
before that's the jam II borscht add
meat hammer knows what you done has the
father if there's need for the use of
women in a collective way for a piece of
music alongside the use of voices of men
is that okay and he says I have managed
to [ __ ] I guess it's a douche the
[ __ ] I ditched an op shop I didn't
eat if it has if it is corrupt or can
lead to corruption
one must distance oneself from that so
it's it's asked whether the the
collective voice of women is allowed and
there he says if it has corruption one
shouldn't do it he doesn't say right
away it doesn't have a you know it's not
problematic again it's condition based
on whether it promotes corruption so
nobody actually asks thing whether the
solo female voice is permitted and now I
want to make a big jump forward so these
uncertainties around music still exist
today of course but in early 2011 in
fact the sort of one model than what one
hears about music in Iran is actually
from one city or Chinese the music is in
limbo the regulations are so vague the
somebody mentioned the notion of
ambiguity as a as a form of policymaking
almost how wielding ambiguity leaves
people in limbo and unable to really
take action and know where they stand
so these uncertain uncertainties still
stand but in early 2011 this sadawa see
my jewelry islamic you know in the state
radio and television of the islamic
republic undertook something
unprecedented and published and
distributed to all radio and television
office
is a 10 page document titled requisites
for the broadcast of music and media
it's a multipack Shenmue serie that
resonate and this is a document that I
managed to receive from the head of
radio research at Siddhartha in Tehran
back then in 2011 it consists of the
most important views on music expressed
by Ayatollah Khamenei the current
supreme leader an addendum of
clarifications on Islamic terms
regarding music and lists of do's and
don'ts
I just want to quick I couldn't really
bring it up on keynote but I just want
to show you what this document looks
like it's so finally up to this point
what would happen was that they there
would be sessions would be held with the
various centers and representatives of
the supreme leader these views would be
and these views could also be
promulgated in fighter prayers for
example and these views would be sort of
passed down to the managers and those
managers again would sort of you know
distribute these views and make clear to
their underlings what the rules and
regulations were even though they
weren't very clear finally in 2011 for
the first time there's a document that
actually states what is allowed and what
is not allowed so I won't actually have
time to go into it but aside from a
number of regulations there's there than
also clarifications on for example Ghana
what what constitutes Ghana what you
know and also some some of the fatwas of
relevant religious authorities on the
issues so one would think that with this
there should have been much more clarity
on on the issue of music and perhaps
even on the female voice but in my
conversations with officials who were
intimately involved with the processes
of negotiating the permissible in radio
and television I came to understand that
really the way this document came about
was that officials within
state television and radio were fed up
with these uncertainties one of them as
senior official within Arby's vetting
bodies dr. hassan al he told me the
source of limitations within the media
has been the views of our marriage it
happily adding as the highest sources of
authority they're very influential
however they do not agree among one
another some regard music is completely
Haram others have conditions under which
it is Hollow eventually it appears
managers within the within state
television radio basically approached
representatives of the supreme leader
Ayatollah Khamenei and said can you not
come forth with with it with a guiding
sort of document for us there was
apparently a lot of protest dr. MacNeill
Lobby be the general director of state
radio research of the state radio
research team told me people were just
scared all the time they would self sent
a sense self-censor because they were
worried that if they broadcast a piece
of music they could get into trouble
perhaps lose their jobs and so according
to la la la be be from the time that
people resolved to express these views
until as that to la cerva me at the time
the head of Cerro Sima asked the supreme
leader to issue written edicts it took
something like ten years for this
document to come about and let me be
told me this is now our foundation and
it makes sense why because the source
who gives us direction Ayatollah
Khamenei is both a high religious leader
Authority and the country's highest
political of a political official many
ayatollahs have positions on religious
principles but mr. Khamenei considers
the political circumstances as well now
no other sources can interfere because
we refer to the guidelines he has given
us after all
the expectation of our channels is that
they make good programs and attract
viewers and listeners and one of our
most important tools in this regard is
music so placing harmony in the ultimate
position of decision making regarding
these matters confirms of course that
the Islamic Republic that while Islamic
foundation
matter it is also the case that due to
the diverging interpretations of these
foundations and because the Islamic
Republic itself is a political entity
many things operate on the policy and
principle of expediency
decisions regarding music are
necessarily based not only on religious
but also on political considerations and
yet harmonies the guidelines have not
eliminated all of the gray areas in
musical policy nor even for that matter
most of them this is in part because the
leaders guidelines still retain the same
ambiguous language several of the items
in the requisites document that I have
here involve forbidding the broadcast of
music that is trite or immoral terms
that are up for interpretation but even
for the more or less clear prohibitions
such as the ban on the solo female voice
the parameters can be flexible that is
because as levy be explained to me
IRB Islamic Republic Broadcasting
officials can send individual requests
to the Supreme Leader's Bureau of
response to religious questions so for
example they asked whether it was
permissible to have a woman solo voice
in the title song of Mostar nami which
was a very popular television series
that was aired in 2010 and 2011
so this epic television series is on the
life of most our Salafi and early Shia
revolutionary who set up a rebellion in
Kufa to avenge imam hussain's martyrdom
because the song was religious and for
the elevation of man mr. Khamenei
allowed it
even though clerics from outside of
state radio and television protesting so
I just want to show you what this
sounded like this there's a solar female
voice in the title track of this
television series aired on Seto seam on
state television
[Music]
[Music]
I should also note that the requisites
document that I had up before in that
document based on the Supreme Leader's
guidance which is based on the Supreme
Leader's guidance is really only meant
for the for use within the strict
confines of state television outside of
the sphere comedy's own jurisprudence
can be more flexible adding to the
confusion toward the end of 2014-2015
the issue of the female voice came to
the fore in the media mostly because of
two incidents namely a concert in
Tehran's unity hall tell her about that
where the female of a singer matthew
mohammed honey sang certain segments
solo and this is matthew mohammed funny
here and this is i having a newspaper
article basically declaring aveline
hernandez an ironic a ballad in la la
banda Majorca the first female Musa
vocalist to perform a show after the
Revolution meaning being the first to
sing solo after the Revolution this was
in the press back then then there was a
CD publication that featured only the
female singer nousheen toffee on the
cover although she was accompanied on
all tracks by a male singer which is
permitted this led to misrepresentations
in the media that lets some Illuma in
turn some clerics in Rome and elsewhere
to believe that the Ministry of Culture
and guidance had given a permit for a
solo female album three sources of
emulation close to hominid issued
statements attacking your shots policies
and reiterating that female singing was
Haram in response the director in charge
of dissemination of harmonies edicts
again very fine print Mohammed was in
fellow Saudi was asked to clarify the
Supreme Leader's jurisprudence on the
permissibility of women singing solo in
public in a widely publicized peace
philosophy responded that ayatollah
khamenei had decreed that if the singing
is not gonna and the listener does not
listen to it with the purpose of
pleasure or without sexual in
since meaning without does not listen to
it without sexual innocence meaning
listens to it without sexual innocence
with sexual innocence
it's how complicated phrasing if it's
free of other sources of corruption it
is halal so a lot of hips so this
however was actually not a sudden change
even though it sounds surprising coming
from Khamenei only six years after
Khomeini's edict last Queen his last
fatwa when no one had dare to ask how
many whether it was okay for a woman to
sing solo people had dared to ask
harmony this is six years afterwards
whether it was okay for them for the
female voice to be brought to be sort of
listened to and I have his here again
it's very fine print but basically
Khamenei is asked Khamenei it's so small
even in my own print that I have a hard
time to rebut estimize today is that not
as an enormous rhyme that moment my but
it is each evoke me that so listening to
the voice of the woman in these
categories it's the one that you see
sort of the long paragraph what is what
is your judgement on within these
categories so whether it's the quran
recitation' marcia funny singing
Marcia's singing national anthems
singing songs sing just sort of usual
general talking or the laughs or crying
of a woman so on all of these counts
Khamenei says his fatwa is the one that
I just read by his spokesperson that if
it doesn't have you know all these sort
of corrupting elements then the voice of
the woman in and of itself is not
problematic so perhaps on the one hand
harmonies religious views are on the
whole more liberal than that of other
conservative Illuma which is something
that Lobby be the radio official was
telling me on the other hand there's so
many qualifications in certain that
short edict that it alludes
clear deduction and only contributes the
general sense of confusion within the
realm of music so it appears that while
through the principle of mass lahat
expediency doing what's in the interest
of the nizam of the state of the Islamic
Republic official policymaking bodies
were able to categorically permit the
use of the use education and
distribution of music they're unable to
apply the same principle to the female
voice they're unable to fully resolve
whether having the solo female voice in
the public sphere having female
musicians appear in public media and
concerts and singing to mix gender
audiences is in the interests of the
state or one might conclude given that
we're now into the fourth decade of the
Islamic Republic that they have in fact
shown through their actions that they do
not believe it to be in the interests of
the Islamic Republic however state
bodies are also less likely to clamp
down on the activities of female
musicians gradually so over the last
four decades their ups and downs so
after the the incidents with Matthew mom
at funny singing some pieces Solo and
told her about that and then that album
cover of Machine toffee there was a big
backlash against female musicians there
were concerts were female
instrumentalists were even asked to
leave the stage but the sort of the
grand arc seems to be sort of you know
going toward more easing of restrictions
and masla or not women musicians
themselves have pushed the boundaries
and their voices are increasingly heard
in the public sphere
they've always been heard in private
nobody stopped listening to female
musicians and private and they're
increasingly more heard in the public
sphere they're not really in the real
public sphere but in the virtual one the
former member of the cha vash that I
mentioned Maggie - Shaunie he was the
composer of the group that performed the
piece in Colorado with Matthew Matheny
singing a piece solo he had been putting
together female all-female ensembles for
a few years now he's got a daughter it
was a singer he's this is really sort of
his his life's work now
and one of his ensembles the my ensemble
published several pieces on YouTube a
couple of years ago which got a lot of
traction in Iran and abroad
it features women all of whom have been
studying and practicing music within the
given permitted framework of the Islamic
Republic the older singer whom you will
see in this video
who Russia Holly Lee has been on several
albums Co singing with others especially
Melanie Sayyidi and other male singers
the space they have created is a tribute
to their own efforts and vision and I
want to just leave you with an excerpt
of this video
[Music]
[Music]
she loved me more robust never take any
[Music]
TV belongs on me I'm to shut me down
[Music]
[Music]
yes sorry I want to listen to it for
longer - thank you hey good evening
everyone I'm not hit thank you so much
for the invitation I'm so happy to be
here so I chose to begin my presentation
with the narratives of the Iranian
musicians that I conducted oral history
interviews with in 2016 as a part of my
master's thesis at the new school an
integral part of my project and its aim
is its hybridity combining
transcriptions historic
contextualization and written analysis
with the voices and narratives of four
iranian women working as musicians today
so between the experiences that were
recounted to me and the representations
like complex mediations entangled in
issues of power political and societal
overlapping patriarchy's contemporary
forms of Islamophobia and the globalized
music industry so now you will hear
excerpts of these oral histories
unfortunately I can't play the whole
thing they're very long but I wanted to
separate some segments so you can hear
their voices and parts of their stories
so these are the locations of all the
musicians that I interviewed there were
four
so what were some of the what was the
biggest obstacle you think you've faced
so far in your life as a musician well I
was a musician definitely the fact that
women cannot sink in when I cannot sing
in my country is has always been a
problem and of course it's it's much
better I mean I'm happy that I can I'm
living out of the country and I'm I can
sing but it doesn't it doesn't solve the
problem at all so it's like but I cannot
see at all but it's totally different
when you're singing your country will be
safer when you can walk on a you know on
a kind of State Street it's anyone is
not safe but also out of you know it's
not that everybody no no worries what
you're doing so you may sound ok
and of course you've got very very
limited obvious which is not terrible to
the people who would listen to your
country and one can understand me and of
course that it really changed your path
you I mean but definitely because
everything works differently for my male
colleagues ethic a fortune in cyberspace
the story is different and syriza more
freedom of any kind so really access is
that people can be ok because the law is
kind of the same for everyone but actual
my system is not fair to say that
different personally you have to
question her grasp you ask generally but
all signals about as a rapper as a
female that I don't talk about that
letting up I was I think most of the
obstacles that there were third cousin
up some people I was a little woman
because there's a lot I can really you
know maybe I said just messin s and
people's mind in your life so funny I
don't know why and [ __ ] what did this
come from
well how hard it like just merged that I
wasn't Baku like that's how I know when
it happens but they work late the girls
there's a certain type of way tie your
scarf at the back up an amazing parkour
and it kind of made I guess your [ __ ]
someone like middle school kids of
another mean but they call those girls
rock girls and even before there was any
brothers in the mirror or something them
that's Providence kind of I don't know
and I was a little small didn't
understand and I remember I swear she's
wrapped rock room you know yeah I'm so
much was this of this that went beyond
that person kind of basis stood I mean
that was subtle breath we heard in the
training school is nobody came from
sophomore something that came from
something not only there but later i
think i think that so we kind of faded
loud because of that small trend yes it
was maddening because also the later
American mainstream the pop up what they
show up in serious them was just you
know party girl movie chains and just
drugs so this always negative charge
is it difficult to achieve that
separation D field people expect you to
be political because you're from Iran
kind of kinds of ways you can tell
people you can kind of kind of run your
image I mean you can construct your own
leaders so also I think people really in
one month
it's innately activist I in somehow very
softly denied that and I try to keep
people concentrated on my music and well
I I know that this in itself is
something I can't solve it I understand
that it's not just it's obvious but I
like to keep people very concentrated
always away in a rally was the wake-up
call for me my Egypt for years I was in
countries anything that happens even for
women or students in Iran for prisoners
even ever got there
we're seeing kneeling or shuffling you
know I want to be there
well then please movement
you know so these are just some of the
excerpts I want to start kind of talking
about my project specifically why I
chose oral history in my works in
academia and as a writer a journalist I
always fall back on this method because
it's revealing of individual
complexities nuances contradictions are
left intact and in this way the
narration retains a more protective
stance against what we usually see on
the media at the same time I as the
interviewer I'm not simply a name at the
top of an article I'm there you hear me
you hear my questions and my slip-ups
are revealed also so a little background
on my research I reached out to 15
Ron young musicians female musicians I
heard back from six and four at the end
were the ones that I managed to arrange
interviews with none of my narrators
were living in Iran at the time but they
were all born there my narrators were
offered a Farsi translator but all
preferred to speak in English and all
opted against remaining anonymous they
all sign release forms and received
copies of their narrations and the
interviews these introduced took place
between October 2015 and February 2016
over Skype as you can tell the quality
is not necessarily the best with video
component enabled in two of the four
interviews with Salome MC and Ziva
Sherazi I used the principles of oral
history and best practices as a guide
the last the interviews lasted anywhere
from an hour to an hour and a half and
two of my narrators were able to speak
with me for a second session so some of
the questions I'd like to begin with as
I contextualize my project is one why is
it important to bring specifically
women's narratives to the forefront of
the question on music in Iran - how is
this problem of fundamental human rights
in Iran tied to and perpetuated by
Western media's representation of
Iranian women specifically and three how
can we as academics researchers
musicians and fans recognize and remove
ourselves from the role we play in a
double bind that only perpetuates the
problem the first question I'm going to
tackle those none of these three I'd
like to refer back to the title of my
presentation and project why is it
important to hear someone's voice and
specifically in this case the voice of
the female musician it's unlikely that a
conference has ever been held on the use
and value of written sources yet when it
comes to oral histories there always
remains a certain doubt as to their
validity and why is that to me one of
its strengths in fact as a methodology
is that it is so frequently analyzed
taken apart and questioned and I'll get
deeper into these questions later on for
now though I would like to focus on it's
the most positive contributing factor to
my project and to its overall
methodology
and contribution to academia which is
the voice and I would like to firstly
contextualize this notion using from
from a sound attorneys perspective
because that's my background also I'm in
his 1972 essay the grain of the voice
French literary theorist Roland Butz
identifies the grain inherent in spoken
or sung vocalizations
as quote the grain is the body and the
voice as it sings the hand as it writes
the limb as it performs unquote the
grain is more than Tom bruh it is the
language of sounds supplementing the
language of sense the summoning not only
have a body but of some sort of
ineffable essence bound to the F ability
of language bartha's thoughts are often
quoted in popular music studies but here
I would like to consider his statement
not to compare singing voices and their
values but to stress the singularity and
significance of the individual voice I
would also like to consider vocalist and
composer Meredith Meredith monk's
philosophy of the voice as a quote
manifestation of the self for decades
monk and her vocal ensemble have been
creating non-narrative collaborations in
which the voice itself is used as a
means for communication monk has stated
time and time again that she considers
the voice to be a quote a language in
itself one that crosses cultural and
linguistic barriers and speaks directly
to people on an intuitive level and
quote now in conjunction with these
ideas I'd like to introduce the oral
imaginary which Roshan a PhD from the
ethnic studies department at UC coined
and explained in a paper of hers that
I'm a very big fan of and I recommend
highly according to russian our caste
contrary to everything she learned about
the Germany of ocular centrism and
specularity in the context of world
music there was instead of phono
centrism she goes on to establish the
ear as a site of oral and effective
interaction between a listener and the
racialized and gendered other of world
music in other words the experience of
musical pleasure in the case of world
muse
is shaped by power relations the
performer in the world music market is
exotic and other more so usually the
Western listener of the world music
genre would not have had exposure to its
conventions and will know little about
the social qualities of the genre beyond
what is included in the marketing of the
music
so with this theoretical background in
mind I'd like to move on to two ideas
that I had in my project two ways of
kind of defining the limits that are on
the female voice in Iran the female
musicians voice I'd like to distinguish
between the disruption of the voice and
the distortion of the voice this quote
from Jacques Attali is indicative of the
target that music is specifically today
and has been throughout time in my study
I explored how it is targeted by the
Iranian government and Western media
though it's certainly in the aim of
other powerful organizations and
structures operating globally today so
the disrupting of the voice I would like
to as I give you some examples but just
to begin the disrupting of the voice we
can see on the ground in Iran today with
censorship these blurred lines and
uncertain restrictions and allowances
and the distortion of the voice we can
see from the outside here in the US and
the media that we consume so mostly on
the Western Front now virtual spaces the
f'n of social media and globalization
perpetuate the notion that every voice
is heard and that we are doing what we
can by retweeting or posting an article
or headline that speaks to us sure the
introduction of a new public space for a
musician to divulge their work is great
but it isn't open to all or free from
manipulations in fact of course the
voices heard in my project are
technically only those with access to
the Internet and I acknowledge this in
my study so this is the situation in
Iran in 2016 according to free muse they
are an international advocacy group that
dedicated
defending artistic freedom of expression
so these numbers here show Iran as the
primary violator of acts against the
freedom of artists for the second year
in a row and music continues to be the
most affected of the art forms
statistics on women are unfortunately
lacking so we already got some very
amazing speakers on you know the history
of music today and I will be reiterating
a few things we heard but this is a very
important part of my project which I
also wanted to go over so the disrupting
of the voice is seen on the ground in
Iran today and is primarily restricted
on apparent religious grounds but in
fact the exclusion of women's voices can
be noted as early as the fourth century
with Paul the apostle's request to quote
let women keep silence in church unquote
and the Catholic churches and trusting
of their musical needs two choirs of men
boys and castrati women instrumentalists
were similarly ostracized during the
Renaissance musical instruments were
attributed male and female
characteristics and identities that
could not conflict with their players so
what was the situation in Iran like for
female musicians throughout the
centuries in fact engravings on the seal
discovered by archaeologists in the
1960s illustrate the first record of a
narked harp in Persia and on the seal is
a group of women singing and playing
instruments it dates back to 3400 BC and
is reportedly proof of the first female
orchestra formed so in time throughout
the Middle Ages in pre-islamic times in
the court traditions of the society
incentives and lack meets female
musicians were generally slaves that
performed for rulers and courtiers we
heard about the ma tribes so it wasn't
until the foundation of the Persian
dynasties around 550 BC that the status
of musicians as a whole experience to
change the so called Macchu absorbs of
musicians male or female that performed
that celebrit ory events and more jobs
in particular are very interesting I
found very interesting in my study to
kind of monitor how their status
fluctuated with prevailing social views
on gender
so during the Safavid and Zonk periods
to 18th centuries female mobs were
actually quite powerful and status
compared to their male counterparts no
this is of course because of the type of
prostitution to to the ma tribes so with
the rise of societal appreciation of
classical and art music however in the
code of art period prostitution was no
longer considered in conjunction with
musical practice and female mobs lost
their powerful status and restrict were
restricted to the anteroom the part of
the house reserved for women the Pallavi
dynasty saw horizon artistic autonomy is
throughout Iran musicians managed to
separate themselves from the patronage
setup to become independent performers
the raha Zi a form of musical show
performed at celebrations changed the
audience performer relationship and that
among performers themselves giving male
musicians dominance over female groups
certain individuals stood out during the
Pallavi dynasty including singer kumara
malukas et who he'd mentioned she was
the first female Iranian singer to sing
without his social and religious
sanction dress code in public she
performed morges AHA bird of dawn the
iconic present asmath with words by
muhammad taqi of aha that invoked the
fear of the people of iran during the
persian constitutional revolution of
1905 to 19 and incidentally this was
sung by hang of morocco bond at the
fodder festival in 2016 which is an
interesting parallel as this song was
used at two different very different
points in time in Iran before the same
purpose to kind of bring the female
voice to the forefront in an act of
defiance
so Iranian women participated in
resistance movements in Iran since the
8th 1892 Baku riots through to the
formation of the Women's Association for
freedom and woman's secret Union founded
in Tehran around the early 1900s and a
very important part of my project was to
constantly stress this that these
resistance movements led by women went
back to 1890 and female musicians for
many years have been establishing and
concretizing their rights to perform and
practice their art
so in the addition to the actions of
individual artists like come on the
support of their community was
essentials to this as well in fact she
took on the last name of a CD because of
the musician all naki was edy who
founded a music school open to women and
encouraged their tents at public events
on music and society
another example is of course the NGO
horatio programs which are amazing and
were established by music lover and
assistant Prime Minister David Pina they
increased literacy rates in a country
where it was at an abysmal 15 percent in
the 1950s so what happened after the
Revolution it's hard to make any kind of
assertion with regard to how life would
have been for female musicians had the
Islamic Revolution not occurred it's
hard to say what did change after the
Revolution were the roles that
specifically the government and the
Revolutionary Guard adopted in this
channeling of music in Iran residents of
village of villages in the countryside
heard their instruments destroyed and
even acclaimed pop musicians such as
gurus were affected her song My dear
loveable sir which had become an anthem
for the Islamic Revolutionary movement
was condemned by the Ayatollah
so voices disrupted many female
musicians left the country and later on
in the post-revolutionary period we can
see a fostering of an environment of
uncertainty among local local artists
especially women performances that are
given permits from the Ministry of
Culture are sometimes canceled at the
last minute these sudden cancellations
are often affecting female musicians and
many of those that attempt to perform
outside of Tehran even now current
president rouhani makes statements like
this one at a press conference in May of
last year quote one of the outcomes of
this year's elections was that everyone
was at peace with music however we are
not too fond of cheap music so it is
this dichotomous position taken by the
holders of powers in the society that
make it so difficult for musicians even
today to know where they stand so
following these examples of the
disruption and the voice of the voice in
Iran I found one disturbing example of
distortion Farzana Milani in words not
swords details a disturbing scene in two
which she visited in in the
post-revolutionary Iran she thought she
heard a woman singing for on lookers at
a restaurant at night but then she
noticed a mustache and trousers then she
wondered if it was a woman disguised as
a man so that she could perform but her
friend explained it was actually a man
imitating a female singer which had
become a trend in Tehran and her friend
asked her if she hadn't heard of mr.
Maha savate her friend said quotes he
impersonates Iranian female singers who
are in exile now honestly you can't tell
the difference
end quote so the exclusion of women from
the public sphere isn't where it stops
there is a strange societal complacency
there as well though I associate actions
on the ground in Iran with disruptions
of the voice in the public space here is
a disconcerting example of the
distortion of the female voice and
acceptance of it as such within and by
Iranian society so as we move on to the
distorted image and voice of the female
musician in Western media I'd like to
start with a quote again by Russia
mukeshji Iran occupies a mystified place
in the Western cultural imagination and
we can see this in several examples I
will show you now from various sources
the first is this is the cover of the CD
and DVD release for a QQ bang-bang in
2008 by goosh and within it was a
handwritten note which in which she
speaks of hurry of the years when her
voice was quote imprisoned and that the
judge of her current journey to the
quote peaks of her voice is you the
audience member so we don't know what
kind of judgement she is awaiting but
there is this mystification of what's
happening and you know what she's been
through
Hameed Natha see a scholar of culture
and diaspora studies suggests that GU GU
Shias absence from the music scene and
20 or so years living in Iran without
performing live mythologized her among
the diasporic
audience and earned
the label of survivor of Iran the captor
now this is reminiscent of the American
experience of the hostage crisis and won
her a great deal of attention by
American mainstream media who rarely if
ever reported on Iranian pop I also find
it pertinent to refer to the opinions
and experiences of reporters journalists
and writers in attendance at a
conference in March 2016 at the new
school titled reporting on Iran can we
know the truth Laura secret stated the
following and this exemplifies the
narrative that many Western media
outlets search for when reporting on
Iran in general another tenant at this
conference Hadi ghaemi
co-founder of the International Campaign
for human rights in Iran separated the
media's focus on Iran into three major
categories one the hostage situation in
Tehran in the 80s second the perceived
threat in Iran posta Lebanon and Israel
in the 90s and finally the nuclear
crisis of the 2000s so according to Hadi
ghaemi all media content is filtered
through the lens of government actions
and policies when in fact according to
him the Iranian government and Iranian
society have been on schizophrenic paths
since the revolution next we have of
course the romances a romanticization of
these threats posed by the government of
censorship and imprisonment and which is
exacerbated by the media here we have a
quote from former director of the condom
festival and that kind of speaks for
itself in its absurdity next we have a
release of a collection of music which
features female Iranian singers it's
marketed on an unclear generalized
statement by Honest John record it's a
label owned by British musician Damon
Albarn
the liner notes read the backbone of the
collection is a set of powerful
performances by women in defiance of the
social stigma attached to professional
musicianship now this there is no
contextualization to this what is the
social stigma professional musicianship
so non professional musicians there is
no stigma attached that I don't know I
find it a little just unclear and my
final example is this part of MTV's
campaign rebel music which had an
episode focused on her
Iran in her narration Salome MC who will
be hearing perform and speak after this
spoke of when the producers reached out
to her to invite her to feature in this
episode but upon feeling it would be a
victimized one-dimensional portrayal she
refused to participate I'd like to play
in just a few seconds of the opening of
the episode that's about it so what we
see there do we see a musician where do
we see a woman a victim got a job you
know what nothing to do with music so
our voices are imbued with the power of
her presentation and Ronnie and female
musicians have fought to keep their
there's heard throughout history the
normative double bind formed by modes of
disrupting and distorting their voices
whether imposed by governmental societal
pressures along with the Western media's
and our aural imaginary subconscious
support of other in perspectives however
will perpetuate a threat against the
Iranian female musicians right to their
own image until confronted head-on as I
begin to wrap with my presentation I'm
almost there I'd like to turn again to
Jacques Attali in noise and politics as
he compares totalitarian and democratic
systems of powers treatments of music
and dedication to the task of
channelization and control of sound
I see Iranian female musicians at the
crux of these two forms of control they
are affected by the totalitarian need to
quote ban submersible if noise because
it betokens demand for cultural autonomy
support for differences or marginality
and quote yet at the same time if
Holly's analysis on the Democratic
systems above is also applicable with
the above problem in mind I have argued
for the invaluable contribution of the
spoken word as an advocate for change a
dialogue between politics and music is
inevitable
the two have been interlocked in a
complex
dance since Plato's Republic however the
storm ative double bind revealed has a
tangling effect on its participants
where there could be constructive
dialogue between music and politics with
potential for cultural enrichment and
societal evolution are instead continued
infringement upon the rights that these
musicians have this tune must change and
one potential path is giving the human
voice agency within academia of course
questions on the likelihood of whether
academic work can change popular
attitudes and the radical potential of
oral history as a methodology will
remain not to the detriment of any work
we do accomplish these are questions we
must challenge in our respective fields
of study and confronts always as the
women's narratives I presented today
show they will do as well thank you
[Applause]
this question for an IEC ever loose
could you tell us a little bit how the
story you tell relates to the film we
watched this is because the film claimed
that the concert that was shown at the
end is the very first time so long women
sang in public and you don't mention
that episode in your papers I'm confused
thank you for that question so the the
performance of the female vocalist at
that particular concert which took place
in 2013
wasn't I think it because it involved
foreign singers didn't actually create
the kind of splash that macking on my
honey's so singing act or F that's
created so following that performance
there were there was there was no press
about you know female women for the
first time sang solo think whilst
revolutionary Iran I think that's in
particular it was makes you know
foreigners and irani in this group and
whereas not even a 20-year sort of the
epitome of you know sort of the Iranian
female vocalist of Persia classical
music and she sang solo act at an event
which was attended by the Minister of
Culture and Islamic guidance even though
subsequently denied it I spoke to magic
the nachshoni
and he said he was there
so basically what it was he was trying
to deny the fact that he was present
while the solo female singing was taking
place so you know I mentioned the two
those two instances Matthew mama again
machine coffee she was built a narrative
of what length or the press and the
clerics - to put a very similar for a
question to Khamenei spokesperson about
his position on the female voice but
it's not that those are the only two
instances you know these instances
happen every now and they're not
necessarily reported upon in ways that
for example I would have maybe seen just
losing you know sort of online media or
even in here maybe not every now that
night it sort of applies the same thing
sort of applies to the showing musical
instruments on state publishers so and
that's another one of the enduring
balance also an enduring red lines of
these long the public is showing musical
instruments on state television but
there have been several instances and I
personally know of about four or five
one of them is very sort of public it
happened in the morning news channels of
channel one they have a whole ensemble
musicians with their instruments in a
morning program which was discontinued
the other ones I know about because I've
talked to a lot of people in the field
of music I don't think I know if I
haven't used where you know sometimes
dead well you know I asked I use a star
said that he actually performs one of
this pieces early on in the ornate 90s
with a grand piano on television so
there are some instances that you don't
have to collect and find out about but
it that that kind of possibility is that
my narrative
because I also remember from as early as
2005 like hid behind album where she was
singing solo but with the very sparsely
outsole under her voice and she had her
picture on the album so they covered a
lot of hunters where the female vocalist
is the main vocalist and their different
strategies they use here too
it also seen but what seems to be
different now is these incidents are
being mobilized to present social media
as scholars how do we continue this
discourse that also say sensitive to the
fact that sometimes being the right
shade of political can be monetized and
it is sometimes mobilized in that way so
how do we strike a balance to deal with
these narratives talk about these issues
but also understand that being the right
political can be very very intent on
right now so it's a good question but
I'm not sure I understand it so when you
you understand look at me being
monetized you mean it's sort of a friend
or I mean I can think of another example
- I remember last year automatically he
went on to expats TV stations and became
in that van
[Music]
so it's like almost I'm music but I can
see being controversial we monetize
their views on how exploited and she was
also so these issues and you know
they're probably some producers
connected to certain people within the
music liberalisation verses these are
just one-off sort of episodes of people
wanting to monetize and create sort of
hype around something for that I think
when it comes to this particular
narrative those two instances big force
those leaders spokesperson to make a
very public statement about so I suppose
there isn't really a way we make sure we
keep those things separate and don't
bring in sort of you know sort of
instances for you know making money but
in the end it that even if it was for
that word was
and so my first question is are you
considering because you you refer to the
laws for television but the laws for
performance for somewhere like tolerance
that he it's completely under a
different institution so you can't
basically use those and apply them for
another you know institution how do you
try to kind of adapt that from this
situation to add another which is more
of that instead of a televised national
you know spectatorship has a live you
know smaller but still in a very
official setting
vision and radio and they are the
scariest so what happened in the States
television is those regulations are the
most conservative they're basically
three sort of you know body that wield
power or authority over certain Spears
of culture reductionists television is
the Minister of Culture and Islamic
guidance which is really in charge of
giving permits for music
records and concert performances and so
on but it doesn't yield a party or what
is done and producing television now but
I'm real sole authority over the rest
and then there's the causal force which
is its own sort of little sort of sphere
of authority and that was it is the
policy making the body that actually
resemble gave permits to to email news
course record anyone that was actually
permitted by the will send not by the
Ministry of Culture so how do we
separate well what happens on States
what sort of the you know the edicts of
the Khamenei and what happens on the
state television or the degree to which
things are allowed or not allowed on
state television while they pertain to
stay television and radio can give us
some notion of whether there's any
loosening of any of those because if it
is the most conservative place that
another thing the strictest laws and
regulations are made the easing of those
would in that space tells us something
outside of that sphere you know the the
baton female voice has been applied
universally in all fields so it's not
that the Ministry of Culture and
guidance has a diserve different set of
regulations on that issue it's an issue
that is so contested and so tied in with
you know the media itself of various
magic happens and it's become so
politicized that if it is to be unlocked
I believe it would probably have to be
unlocked first and the most conservative
they
with other institutions to feel safe
because you know all these institutions
are run by people at the end of the day
are worried of their positions and their
jobs and what they can do and what they
cannot do and just this summer there was
a performance e-collar that he a dance
performance just for women they weren't
allowed to perform it last minute it's
because the show got canceled and the
same show was performed just a month ago
same place but the only only change here
only element that change was that well
the director of the show had an High
Line online television interview when
you know what have you online inter
internally produced programs in Iran so
things can be that easy I mean nothing
changed there or no element just that
was that you know that interview creates
it for a while you know yeah that's
interesting I mean it's it's really that
element of you know sort of almost sort
of haphazard nasur an immunity that
gives the state that kind of power to
meal and he leaves people in that state
so in that particular case you know
there's there's also a lot of going and
coming and negotiating and ultimately
this I mean no right ultimately I think
with what means what one needs to do is
actually speak to the people who are
involved because you do end up finding
out really surprising and interesting
things about how these things come about
in the house or you know how for example
pop music was fine sort of you know
relighted toward the late 90s and there
there's about there but for myself I
haven't spoken to the people were deeply
involved in that process I wouldn't
really have known that would have just
guessed that perhaps they wanted to go
against the title you know Western music
finding music coming in from Los Angeles
so I'm not sure but I was actually one
of the performance yes performers there
so tell us well that's the case that's
basically first of all it was before the
change of cabinet and the other one was
that my teacher decided to interviews it
was some internet but very kind of
built-in use internet television show
and to change between I mean what all I
am saying is that many things they need
on our season off so it's true that you
know there are laws but there are all
these elements that come and go I'm you
never can tell yeah which is why I
pointed to the you know issue of the
guilty even of the laws and they're not
there I mean you know there's this
finally sort of my book you know have
sort of like a directive to people and
state television maybe about what to do
and what not to do it but at the same
time the terminology is so big that once
again they can be interpreted in various
ways and value temple my Larry's
football I could take a question from
that young girl over there oh sorry
[Music]
why me why and singers do like
sweetheart okay so
right you like them yes you know I like
shiny soft spot for hide it
I thank you both for such really great
presentations um I have a question about
voice and silence so mostly we've been
talking both of you have been talking
about the fight for voice and this is a
question mostly for table but also I
think it relates to both presentations
so I'd be curious to hear both of your
responses I'm wondering in this fight
for voice how silence has been narrated
of Pavel especially by your
interlocutors and if there are any
subversive engagements with silence or
silence as a strategy of resistance and
subject formation and I'm curious how
your India interlocutors have engaged
with silence mine really was
self-censorship I think you know like a
lot of my narrators you know for
preservation reasons for reasons you
know to continue their careers to
establish themselves as musicians
resorted to self-censorship so adopting
Manik for other names to go by inserting
themselves into the underground music
scene or and stuff like that like that
field when you mentioned silence that's
what I think you know it's
self-censorship like removing yourself
from that place from the public space
where you can be subject to limitation
on your voice and stuff like that so for
in minor actions that's where I kind of
saw the signers and there is definitely
you know a soft preservation and the
merchant aspect to that and yeah that's
how musicians before word and establish
themselves despite I I agree with
politics it's a it's a sort of method of
resistance at you if you will that's
something now musicians have you so
having something exactly simply refused
to she didn't just you know stop singing
in public she just gave up singing
altogether for a while until she had the
chance to go abroad and give a concert
and then she restarted her activities
and has been giving concerts since but
not in Iran so she continues that method
of silence as do other thing is I
mentioned Maxwell back that and there's
series of others who simply refuse to
sing within the parameters of the Slovak
Republic even to all-female audiences
because they leave and this is something
that I wanted only mentions in her book
that automatically putting women in a
category on their own denigrates their
form of art making puts them in it and
you know I happen to all female concerts
and Yvonne and I have to say there's
there's there's there's truth to that
there's less of an enforcement of the
kind of you know customs and regulations
or you know customs that we have and
getting respect to a performance and
keeping quiet and although that they're
they're much less sort of kept an
all-female
performances there's a lot of noise from
you know chips eating and women talking
and you know and with these all-female
performances often times also women find
this finally sort of this public space
though all-female that's still this
public space a way that can be sort of
free and and relate to each other and
enjoy its way and all the times they won
the musician to play you know something
fun and something making dance - as
opposed to sort of whatever pieces the
muse
the self may have prepared the same so
not for taking in that scene and keeping
silence is a way of expressing that
protest of that sort of bifurcation and
integration of their one question down
here my previous company I did this
basically but um you know we've been
talking a lot about the difficulties of
females performers finds after the
Revolution but it seems to me and the
stigmatization of musicians and
performers is nothing new it was there
before the Revolution and women
performers were very much they with
Sigma ties and sometimes they'd be
threatening to be killed by their
relative and then on but that at that
time it was a bona boxing it was not
from the top down and now we have the
same thing the same type of
stigmatization when it's coming from the
top down and I asked you what you
thought that idea that was that
musicians performers get the short stick
all the time no of course I I wanted to
go through as briefly as I could before
the farmers fiction kind of like the
historical what I found like these
little clips is through the history of
what it was like female musician in Iran
and you know their representation and
what they simple what they had for
people like how they were viewed by
people and of course I feel like at the
same time I don't know from the
narrations that I conducted
and I spoke to I feel like it isn't only
from the top down right now I feel like
it's still coming from within society
but the families one of the things I
really want to expand upon in my
research in the future is being of
course I want to be on the ground in
Iran and I want to speak to women
outside up to run and get a sense for
you know what it's like for them because
I have a feeling it's not definitely not
just the government that's in their way
you know I feel like it's it's more than
that we don't hear about it but I'm
thinking I don't know you you live there
but I don't know much has changed in
that regard if anyone does and someone
comment for you that fed ball of
Khomeini that you showed I asked mr.
Malla tell me about it he's in London
and he says that this term it's or this
is a device that is almost always used
in these bedbugs because every Ayatollah
has our own following and I don't want
to step on anybody's toes
so my give their opinion they said when
it's up to or at the answer this is
actually like a a rhetorical device that
they use you know so they can't get
stuck out very nice thing um I also want
to mention very quickly I think they
acted sort of cut short the Q&A session
and response dear I agree the pressure
is also from bottom up not just from top
down and I spoke very recently to a sort
of third generation rapper now so Salome
is you know Iran's first female hip-hop
musician there now have been you know
the third generation is quite young I
think she might be sort of you know one
of the older ones of the third just
juice Tina and she was saying you have
you know things really changed in her in
her private life and her personal life
if she started rapping and putting her
videos online people had she's you know
an a young woman who lives in Tehran
people instantly started looking at her
differently and in in the interview with
me
even says something like I am no longer
because I because I'm putting myself out
there it is considered that I do not
have the kind of shame that is valued in
Iranian society and I'm no longer that
girl who's necessarily on the trajectory
to marry and have children and whatnot
I've sort of left that trajectory this
is you know a woman in her very early
20s in Iran right now okay at the
recommendation of dr. Sanders to wrap up
this
[Applause]
[Music]